hi
everyone welcome to uh this
month's monthly uh inference colloquium
as part of our series on trying to
understand
the nature of correlation and causation
and it gives me great pleasure to um
introduce our wonderful speaker for
the talk today um dr eric winsberg
but before i give you a brief
introduction
um to his intellectual trajectory and
his work
i would like to say thanks to our
benefactors
mr and mrs richard and barbara frankie
who are unfortunately not joining us
today
but um their support of the frankie
program
and many other activities at yale is
gratefully acknowledged
so i also want to remind all of you that
we are recording this event and
therefore all participants
must therefore mute their videos and as
per usual and customary at the end of
eric's talk
we will have your
questions which you can feel free to
type up in the chat
um as we go along and we'll have a q a
session um
at the at the very end so i also wanted
to remind everyone that
in addition to today's lecture um
in the in this colloquium series we have
sort of the discussion
session that happens tomorrow at the
same time
at 3 p.m tomorrow we will have a
discussion
of eric winsberg and the conversant this
time
is going to be dr stephanie harvard who
works is a postdoctoral research fellow
at the university of british columbia
and
uh in the faculty of pharmaceutical
sciences
so uh first um moving on to today's talk
i just wanted to give you a a brief
sense of eric's
intellectual path and his research
interests
i first got to know of eric when i read
his work on
simulations um really um
radical rethinking of how to understand
simulations and modeling in the context
of
sciences and a range of sciences
so eric got his phd from indiana
and uh following a postdoctoral
fellowship
in history and philosophy of science at
northwestern
he joined the philosophy department as a
faculty member at the
at usf and he joined
he went there in 2001 and has remained
there since
his principal interests are in the
philosophy of science
in particular the philosophy of climate
science and the philosophy of physics
he is particularly interested in the
role of computer simulations in
physical sciences and analog simulation
in cosmology
and in the foundations of statistical
physics and the direction
of time many of you would have heard him
uh he was our conversant with carlo
rovelli
which was sort of the opening talk of
our series
um his um he also writes on
truth and on scientific authorship it's
a really wide-ranging set of
uh interests he's the author of several
articles on all of these topics that
appeared in all the top journals like
philosophy of science journal of
philosophy the british journal for the
philosophy of science
studies in the history and philosophy of
modern physics and synthesis
he has held numerous visiting
fellowships
and has a lot of um honors
uh was a fellow at the institute for
advanced study at the university of
durham in the uk
at the university of california berkeley
at mcmp in munich
and the university of luenberg in
germany
so he has two wonderful books
um which are out already uh the first
one is science in the age of computer
simulation from the university of
chicago press
and uh philosophy and climate and
climate science
which was published by cambridge
university press and he has a
forthcoming book cambridge elements and
philosophy
of science on models in science over the
last year
during the pandemic eric has focused on
the use of models and methods
of causal inference in the covit 19
pandemic
extremely important work as many of you
know that
during the pandemic we really saw the
provisional nature of science
and how we can draw limited inferences
as we get to know more and more about
the disease we saw all of that play out
right in front of our eyes we all had
front row seats to how this was
happening so we really look forward to
hearing eric some of your thoughts on
on this and hopefully you will come
cover some of this material today
so when he's not uh tapping away on his
laptop working um
working you can often find him on the
water in his stand-up paddleboard oh
that is the joy of people who live in
lovely climates what can i say
very envious eric so um the title of his
talk today
is causal inference and complex
non-linear systems
a cautionary tale so thank you so much
eric for
agreeing to speak in this series and we
are absolutely delighted
and take it away please thank you
let me see if i can get this okay great
so just to give people a little bit of
background nutria has already
told you that i've worked a lot on uh
philosophy climate science i
finished my book up on uh philosophy
climate science in about 2017
and uh i was going out to california uh
you know a year and a half ago
and i wanted to start thinking a little
bit more about uh
how modeling ought to inform policy
because i've really been focusing
mostly just on the modeling itself and
i'm sort of
trying to make a transition to thinking
more about
having more sort of policy oriented
focus to my research
and that was in you know january of 2020
and then we all know what happened uh in
the next couple of months
which made it pretty you know pretty
obvious to me that i ought to be
focusing on uh this you know very new
area in which models were informing
policy
in a pretty you know quick and and and
and uh
impactful sort of way um and so you know
one of the things i
i hope we can sort of get around to uh
in this session is think is talking
about
what kinds of uh what kinds of ways
modeling on an informed policy what
constraints there ought to be on models
that inform policy that kind of stuff
but uh you know because uh because of
the sort of theme of the conference
i wanted to just focus a lot on uh you
know the theme of the conf
of this this series being um the
relationship between correlation and
causation i wanted to focus on
some of the stuff i've been watching uh
about how we've made causal inferences
over the course of the pandemic
and then i'm hoping like tomorrow um as
stephanie joins the conversation
we can kind of broaden the conversation
back to the general topic of how models
ought to inform policy
okay so let's see how does this here we
go so um a lot of this kind of started
uh when um early you know my interest in
this kind of started
early in the pandemic and i had to go
back to the wayback machine
on the internet to find this because
unfortunately didn't screenshot it at
the time
but this was um you know the financial
times circa
march 29th i think it is 2020
um showing us the course of the pandemic
uh in a variety of countries and one of
the things i found fascinating about
this chart
was all these little um all these little
uh
blurbs that get inserted here sort of
explaining
uh the course of the pandemic in all
these countries so italy had the highest
death rate because of a large elderly
population
south korea had a low death rate because
of early large-scale testing and tracing
um spain uh locked down after 200 days
but france locked down after 175 days
and that's why
spain is a little bit ahead of france
japan i had to write this one in myself
because i
i definitely remember this being on here
but i didn't find the version that sent
it
japan had a culture of masks and bowie
and that was you know responsible for
uh where they are on the chart um and a
lot of what this room
immediately reminded me of was uh
an episode in the history of uh of
climate science
which kind of lasted from about 1998
till 2012
uh and it was known as the it was known
as the warming hiatus
and there was a lot of there was a lot
of ink spilled over this hiatus that was
thought to have been happening
between 1998-2012 and you can kind of
see it here
right um so the green line is
uh the concentration of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere
which you know all climate scientists
agree
results in in warming of the planet and
yet this this red line here which was
tracing out
uh the global average surface
temperature of the planet
uh seemed to hit kind of a slow patch
in about 1998 as you can see in the
chart between
1998 and 2012 there wasn't a lot of
net warming of the planet and this
caused a lot of consternation among a
variety of parties
and people immediately wanted to know
why why is there this
hiatus and of course people who were
opponents of uh climate mitigation
uh who were doubters of the existence of
climate change
uh declared it to be a major problem
right so this is the telegraph
in 2006 there is a problem with global
warming
um and that is stopped in 1998
um and immediately i think uh climate
scientists
felt the need to explain this why
why why did the war remains stop in 1998
and there were i think sort of two
causal questions here two explanations
one was um why why this why the slowdown
right so just the brute fact that the
warming of the planets seemed to have
paused maybe uh so just the brute fact
itself
um and then there was this what was
perceived to be this modeling mismatch
right so if you look in this if you look
at this picture
um what you see the kind of grayish
black line here
that's kind of heading inexorably upward
um
that was the predictions of the the
so-called the cement
the climate model into comparison
project which kind of averages together
uh the forecast of a variety of plant
models and then all these little colored
lines
which were the actual um data sets of
various
uh meteorological and climate uh
agencies around the world like the
hadley center in the uk
and national atmosphere national ocean
uh social united states
so um so you know there was a brute fact
uh warming seems to have paused and then
this modeling mismatch
and the question was why um and there
were you know sort of a variety of
explanations
uh this is wrong paper in 2015
uh by by thorn and others kind of
going through a variety of plausible
explanations of why the pause happened
you know maybe it was variations in el
nino uh maybe it was some volcanic
eruptions maybe it was
a quiet solar cycle maybe it was changes
in stratospheric water vapor
so you know climate scientists i think
felt the pressure to explain this pause
uh came up with a variety of
explanations um and then of course
uh you know um the other side said oh
you know
they're just look at all these excuses
right so this is this kind of
uh notorious um climate skeptic uh blog
what's up with that uh and you know uh
here you get from 2014 a list of excuses
for
uh for the pause of course
um you know uh in the end uh i need to
start
dragging my windows i see this in the
end right as we look at this
you know running all the way from let's
say about 1900
up to the present you can still see this
little pause here between about 1998 and
about 2012
but in the great scheme of things right
um it's pretty clear that nothing
particularly interesting or important
was that
was happening here there was you know
just maybe a little bit
of internal variability uh swamping the
overall trend so
the clear trend here from 1900 to about
2020
is warming and you just get right you
get in this about 14-year period for
whatever reason uh you get some internal
variability in the climate that is that
is swamping
swamping the trend um and and then you
know also i think
one of the other things that people sort
of overlooked in uh if we go back and we
look at this picture
right why why is there uh why is there
this sort of pause in the data
but this very smooth increase in the
predictions the models why don't the
models also
predict this kind of internal
variability you might ask
um and the answer there i think is also
rather simple uh the seamepism is a
it's a climate model intercomparison
project
so it's a it's an amalgam of uh you know
averages over a variety of different
flat models
um and that's just apt to smooth out uh
let's just have to smooth out
each model had you know probably had a
similar amount of internal variability
as the actual uh data did but when you
average them together
uh you got something that looked quite a
bit smoother okay
so um so there was a rather simple
answer to the question
um why was there a a warming hiatus
and and the real answer was well it's a
complex non-linear system
and complex manual systems just do weird
things they
they behave in kind of um you know
sporadic
and jumpy and clumpy ways um
and there's a danger right i think when
you see the behavior of nonlinear
systems
is going to be one of my main themes
today there's a danger when you see the
erratic behavior of a nonlinear system
to think there must be an explanation
for these things
and i think we saw that happen quite
quite a bit um
in that period of climate history
when there was this um when there was
this and so when i when i
started seeing these pictures in uh in
financial times
with all these explanations of each one
of these each one of these
uh graphs uh
it you know sort of set my alarm bells
off um maybe
something similar is going on here um
and another sort of i think you know
uh thing that we saw in the in the
climate hiatus case is that
data are always uncertain right data
array is uncertain and one of the things
that's
one of the things that you know drives
all of the
uh the mystery in this chart right uh
is that supposedly sorry supposedly all
of these
all of these graphs supposedly are are
um
synchronized uh beginning when um
the number of deaths in that country
reached 10
right but but we now we now know i think
in retrospect that this was all a
fantasy
right um we had no idea when each of
these countries reached their 10th death
um there was a nice recent really
careful recent paper
um that in the journal of infectious
diseases i think it was
that um i did so many people have been
doing now for months but did it very
carefully
and showed that you know by january by
sort of middle of january 2020
there were already cases of of
a cobig-19 infection in a
fixer stock i remember it was six or
seven u.s states so they just went and
looked at
um you know uh blood blood donors from
that period
so you know we really don't know we
really don't know when any of these
countries have their 10th death
um and so all of this lining up and all
of this like that was all relatively
um just uh you know
an artifact of the way that the data was
being collected at the time we really
don't know how to line up these
different countries with respect to when
they when they're when their epidemic
started
um and and sort of over the course of
the pandemic
we've been you know we've been subjected
to um
a lot of causal inferences um
and uh i think one of the other things
that happens
when you have a lot of noisy data with a
lot of
uh clumpy quirky jerky behavior in it
um people will often find what they want
to find just as in the in
in the in the climate case people who
didn't believe in climate change
uh took that as an opportunity to say
that they they were finding this
so i think in in the pandemic um people
have been able to
find what they want to find so here's a
you know here's a
um an article that ran in a a bunch of
news outlets
i think the associated press started
this it's from right after
the election obviously november 6th of
2020
and it tells us that u.s counties with
the highest fire surges
overwhelmingly voted for trump um
and you know when this came out my first
thought was okay well you know maybe
that's just
kind of um again just
some kind of spurious correlation here
maybe there's something to this
but then of course once you dug into the
data a little bit what you realized was
that um it's true that uh the u.s
counties with the highest virus surges
overwhelmingly voted for trump
but it's also true that the counties
with the lowest various surges
overwhelmingly voted for trump um and
there's
a simple explanation for this and that's
that uh
uh the counties that voted for trump
were on on the
we're on the whole smaller counties than
the counties that voted for biden
so we know that we obviously we all know
that um
rural america tended to vote more for
trump and urban america voted for biden
rural counties are smaller small samples
have more variants
um and so small samples tended to have
that
the trump counties tended to have either
very large numbers of coronavirus
or very low numbers of chronovirus they
just had right they just had
the noisier samples in them um that was
primarily what was going on here
um and then we also you know very very
soon we were looking at people were
trying to find evidence
of that various you know public health
measures of various kinds
uh were effective um so we're very
people remember this right but we very
very quickly went from
um a pretty broad consensus
in uh say february march of 2020
among public health experts that um that
masks were not really something that the
public ought to be
concerned about um and then quickly you
know quickly that that scientific
consensus changed
and so there was there was a lot of work
trying to try to show this
um and uh um you know a lot of it really
kind of was
uh pretty quick and dirty uh so
uh this was a study that came out in um
uh so it was published in october of
2020
uh got recorded in a lot of outlets this
is a cnn article that's that's referring
back to the study
um and and what what did what was the
study doing
the study was merely going back to um
uh kind of late april early may
uh in the pandemic and it was uh
sort of linearly extrapolating um these
curves right
well linearly in the log scale right so
in other words sort of exponentially
extra
extrapolating them and then just sort of
trying to say okay well what is what's
the thing that happened
right before some of these curves are
turning down oh lo and behold right um
lo and behold it's it's masks so not
really that not really um
a super um rigorous way of establishing
causal hypotheses
um you know we uh we
and you saw lots of lots of studies like
this where this was really the method
that was being used you would just get
somebody would would kind of take a
particular place in this case it was the
delaware
it was the delaware department of health
data um on
uh uh on uh infections in delaware
and people just sort of putting the you
know putting what they took to be
the dates on which some of these public
health interventions happened
and then trying to line them up with
bumps and the curve
whereas you can pretty clearly see that
that you've got just kind of a fairly
noisy and bumpy curve here um and then
just sort of trying to
trying to draw um uh causal
uh hypotheses out of this um and you
know this was kind of
this was something that i um that i
posted um on facebook just to make fun
of us right
but um so i'd been in california right
until
on june 15th we came back from
california we returned to florida
um and this was you know a chart of the
hospitalizations in florida
and of course right very easy to just
say oh okay look here here's when
here's when eric returned to florida and
look what you know look what happened
to hospitalizations in florida right
after that
but of course that's not a particularly
uh effective way of drawing
uh causal emphasis um and you know we
were also then
i think we saw a lot of things like this
happen uh so this was a scientific
american ran this
story in september 15th 2020 um how new
mexico controlled the spread of cobit
19. so we were very eager right to go
find places where it looked like um
there was success in mitigating the
epidemic
try to figure out what what did those
places do um
and say oh okay that that must be you
know the fact that new mexico
has controlled the spread they must have
the secret sauce
for uh for making us uh for making this
work and of course
this was one of the most um ill-timed
uh articles of the pandemic uh
you can see it here in a chart of uh
uh the case rate in new mexico right so
um
here's the the article comes out on
september 15th how new mexico controlled
the spread of covenant 19
and then there's the uh there's what
happened just a couple of weeks
um similar kind of uh similar kind of
event here right um here we have this is
a
uh an article that ran in um
in germany uh you know it's homborg
proof that an emergency break
can get covered 19 cases down uh
so they were trying people thought okay
look homework is doing really well
they must be must be establishing
something must have some
effective method of doing this but of
course a couple of things right
um as with many of these things this was
just you know always these things tend
to come out right before
things would get bad but sort of also
interestingly right it's interesting i
think to line up
um the uh this is you know ic
utilization for kevin 19 patients per
million population
comparing um the the hamburg uh
sort of administrative region what they
call the balloon island and uh the
stockholm
i guess the sort of stockholm county
stockholm lawns
um and you can see right that um pretty
clearly whatever is going on
uh in these places uh is something
is something fairly regional right and
so
um any attempt to kind of you know look
for the interventions
that homborg was carrying out these nice
places
closing uh restaurants having mass
mandates
closing shops uh making
uh masks uh required in private cars
having curfews etc and you can sort of
see right people are
going through this and attributing these
various zigs and zags
in the graph to all these things but you
know we know right that
um we know that stockholm was not doing
these things
um and given that stockholm and hamburg
are kind of
proximal to each other have similar
climate uh
are sort of under whatever whatever
makes these
uh whatever makes these curves come and
go plausibly were
you know being affected by them um in
relatively similar ways
uh we can see right that um you know
this of course i don't want to suggest
that
i i can make better inferences myself
but it does seem
it does seem sort of uh at least primo
fascia plausible
that these are these attributions of the
of the various
zigs and zags of the curve to these
interventions is is spurious here
uh we also you know saw lots of um we
saw lots of
cases like this this was a a a very
widely cited
um and influential study by
uh so monica gandhi here is the uh the
last author on this but i suspect
probably the
one of the uh that's one of his last
authors who's really the main author
uh she was a a major um
you know uh
leader in in in
providing evidence for the effectiveness
of mass mandates uh so this was a paper
that came
that uh posted on november 4th um
and uh the paper was withdrawn uh i
forget exactly what the
timeline between provocation withdrawal
was but but they went through it for
they say here the authors have withdrawn
this manuscript because there are
increased cases
of starscope 2 uh in the areas we
originally analyzed the study so
you know here they were they've taken
some places where there were mass
mandates some places where they were not
mass mandates they used very statistical
methods to show that
uh the case rates had grown in the
places where
there weren't mass mates and and hadn't
in the places where there were
but then of course you know within
within a month or two um
they had to withdraw the paper because
uh many of the places that they were
claiming had been uh you know saved by
the mass mandates
were just catching up with the places
that didn't have the past mandates
a little while later um
uh and then you know we one of the
things i want to talk about especially
is
uh this was a this was a paper that came
out um
in december 2020 but i believe appeared
uh
on the on a you know in a in a
pre-current form a
couple or maybe three months earlier um
that
uh used a method called um uh
synthetic controls i want to talk about
a little bit today uh
to show that face masks uh had
considerably reduced
kerbin 19 cases in the parts of germany
that instituted mass mandates
i mean i think again that sort of that
evidence kind of seemed to evaporate uh
over time um but this was this was i
want to talk about this a little bit
because
a lot as sir you know early on right we
were seeing like you know the financial
times thing where
just really sort of crude causal
attributions you know oh here look
here's a chart this is because of my you
know this is because of a culture of
bowing or whatever
sort of really um uh you know very fast
and loose inferences like that
over time this this method of synthetic
controls became
sort of really uh became um quite
prominent in trying to be
more careful uh in establishing these
things um
so in that paper by this group right you
find this this quite
you know strong sentence which has a
detailed analysis of the timing of all
public health measures
in the region we study guarantees that
we correctly attribute our findings to
face masks
um and not erroneously to other public
health measures so i'm
going to get to this in a bit but i want
to talk a little about the synthetic
control method
um and maybe suggest reasons why um
it's not quite the magical that many of
the people were trying to use it
over the last year claimed it was um
this is another one this was another
sort of famous uh
pretty widely shared headline that this
was based on a study that used the
synthetic control method
uh that tried to show that the sturgis
motorcycle rally
uh which happened in south dakota in
uh june i guess uh was responsible for
maybe may
was responsible for a large amount of
the spread so you may remember that
the upper midwest kind of had its big
wave uh
right around the time of this motorcycle
rally so
um okay so um i just wanna step back a
little bit
uh and talk about um non-linear
phenomena and why
or you know just sort of illustrate that
non-millionaire phenomena tend to have
interesting patterns
that don't really call for explanation
so um here's a this is maybe one of the
most classic
examples of a non-linear phenomena this
is a double pendulum
right it's a it's a pendulum on the end
of a pendulum
and when you watch something like this
swing
you can just see right that it it just
goes through these moments where it kind
of
spins wildly and then kind of slows
down a bit and then we'll swing lively
later
i mean anybody who watched something
like this and thought oh i want to
i want to try to explain why why you
know time
at eight seconds into it did it start
spinning furiously and then 12 seconds
into it
stop spinning furiously um you could you
know
if you had if you had a wild imagination
right you could imagine coming up with
all kinds of explanations
uh for why this kind of thing is
happening but um
it's just it's just it's it's the nature
of the double pendulum
right and it's part of the nature of it
being a nominator system
uh then it just exhibits these uh quite
interesting
sporadic things and here's just this is
actually a simulation
just because um uh fluids are a little
harder to visualize than pendulums but
you can see this in real data too
this is so-called rally bernard
convection in our convection
where you have a hot plate on the bottom
and a cold plate on the top
of some fluid um and pretty quickly
right
you can see that all kinds of
interesting
patterns start to form uh and
and anybody who was not familiar what
was going on here
uh and wanted to then explain why is
there a you know dark red patch here
and a dark blue patch here and you know
why does this thing have
uh why is this thing displaying all the
patterns that it is
uh you can kind of give a global account
of why it has the sort of
general you know why why does it have
why does it have a generally sort of
you know eddie structure but if you
tried to explain you know why
is why is there a big red eddy here and
a big blue eddy over there
um you'd be you'd be pretty quickly
getting yourself
into uh into trouble here
okay so just just uh you know a few
things i think worth noting about
nonlinear systems
right um we just we just know this from
from study of a wide variety of systems
they can display a drop transmit they
can display abrupt transitions
in responses to small changes right so
if
um if you had you know two uh fluids
next to each other
one that was exhibiting shallow
convection and one that was exhibiting
deep
convection uh an inexperienced observer
might think there was some deep
substantial cause or factor
responsible for that difference right
they would look at these two convective
systems and say look they look radically
different there must be some
there must be some explanation for why
this one's undergoing deep convection
and that one is going shallow and
they're going shallow convection
but the only explanation that there
would be would be
a very microscopic and very cognitively
unsatisfying one it would be
if you could in fact if you you know if
you were really had an unbelievably
detailed module system
you might be able to track it down to
some very small difference
uh and identify what that small
difference was right it wouldn't be due
to nothing
um but it wouldn't be the kind of thing
that somebody who was inexperienced and
he was looking for
um who was looking for uh something like
that uh so similarly
right we know that avalanches um we know
the avalanches can be caused if you have
a pile of sand
right one very you know ill-placed grain
uh added to an otherwise stable pile and
can cause a massive avalanche
perhaps more relevant to pandemics right
we know that if you have like a lattice
of nodes
um and you you just assign random
connections between those nodes
and then you look at whether there's a
you know how many paths there are from
the top to the bottom
very a very tiny change in the
probability of connections
right can sort of massively give quality
sort of big quality of changes
to what to the number of paths that
you'll find between top and bottom
so a lot of times that sort of take home
lesson here right
is that a lot of times um these kinds of
behavioral changes
that you see in nonlinear phenomena cry
out for explanation
even though uh the true explanation is
often
microscopic um nearly impossible to
identify and i think really you know
not just i want to say cognitively
unsatisfying
just in the sense that it's not it's not
a kind of thing
that uh as human beings we
when we encounter these kind of
phenomena it's not the kind of thing
that we typically are inclined to
attribute
uh the explanation to um
as just a picture of jupiter here right
with its famous red spot which is just
another one of these sort of coherent
structures that emerges
uh out of a non-linear system that if
you wanted to know if you lived on
jupiter and you want to know why is
there
why is the red spot here um you would
not get a very commonly satisfying
answer
okay so so one of the main take-home
lessons here of the talk
um is uh um when you have these three
things together
right a normal you know a system that
exhibits a fair degree of nonlinearity
a sort of rich causal menu available to
you
right think of the think of the original
um a little financial times chart
you know uh who locked down when who has
a culture of mass growing and bowing
who had an elderly population who was
using test and trace who was doing
so you have a rich causal menu that you
can appeal to
right um and right uh something that you
know i think this is
uh a famous anthropologist uh evans
pritchard
noted this when he was studying the the
azande in africa right
that it's a pretty common feature of
human beings that when people get
sick or when bad things happen to people
they immediately are looking for
explanations in the form of why here why
now why is this happening to me
why is it happening here not there um
what's going on
i think when you get these three things
together right
non-linearity a rich causal menu that
you can appeal to to explain those
things
um and it is and a desire right a sort
of urgent desire to know
why is the pandemic bad here but not
there why is it happening to us
but not them why why were they saved and
we're not
um i think these three things together
often lead to
um to dangerous inferences
um and just just to give you a little
taste of this this was kind of
as i started thinking about this i was
like there's got to be a really good
there's got to be a really good example
of this
uh from the history of science and um
the thing that occurred to me i was
thinking about different nonlinear
systems
earthquakes right of course um the
results of nonlinear phenomena
and there was a whole industry in the
sort of late mid to late 19th century
of trying to understand what caused
earthquakes right again because
earthquakes
were displaying exactly this kind of
clumpy
uh non-linear based
kind of dispersion of of uh of data
so you get people you know you get all
these people in late 19th century
arguing about
is it due to atmospheric pressure is it
due to
the seasons is it due to the position of
the moon is it
due to the position of the sun and
much like i think much like many of
these things not only
do you in these cases have this kind of
rich data with
you know all kinds of you have a large
causal menu right these people are like
looking at
what they want to know what causes
earthquakes and they immediately imagine
these are the things that might be
causing responsible right they're not
they're plausible
atmosphere pressure position on the moon
position the sun tides
things like that they have you know this
messy clumpy data
and then of course what we what we now
know too is that their data
were bad they had they didn't have first
of all they didn't know
as we now know that most of the
earthquakes on the planet happen
underneath the oceans so they were
missing you know at least
70 percent of the earthquakes um and
they're there you get a lot of you know
you get a lot of disagreement between
these scientists that all boils down to
they're looking at different data
right so you have one one person saying
oh you know it's clearly
it's clearly the position of the moon
and then someone else using
their data saying no look i can clearly
show that there's no relationship
between uh between the moon and uh
and uh and earthquakes
right okay but but these were these were
19th century rubes right
um we have uh we have much better data
than they had
we had much better um methods of
inference than they do
right surely we can do better um uh
and uh surely we can surely we can
identify
the causes of differential outcomes in
the pandemic
um well it's so a number of things i
think
are confounded here so i just want to
show you this is a nice little picture
that i like
this is based on uh so oxford has been
running this
um uh since
uh pretty early on the pandemic they've
been tracking what they call the
stringency index
uh for for different places that's meant
to be a sort of one number
summary of how aggressive public health
measures have been
in various places and trying to control
uh the pandemic
um and you can plot them here for at
least the the
u.s states um so you know here you have
uh here on the horizontal axis you have
this oxford stringency index
um from march averaged over march 2020
to may 2021
uh here you have uh kevin 19 that's 400
000. uh the size of the blob is the
is the sort of you know so california is
the biggest blob texas is nice and big
hawaii is a tiny little dot right uh the
red states are red
the blue states are blue the purple
states are purple we all know what that
means
um and you know if you look at this at
least with the naked eye it looks like
maybe there maybe there's some
interesting patterns here maybe there's
maybe there's some
uh maybe there's some uh degree of
covariance here but it's not
entirely obvious um but what's
interesting right is
uh the various ways that people can kind
of uh
cherry pick uh examples and make the
cherry picking look plausible
so this is i think you saw a number like
a lot we heard a lot about this about
about people argued about sweden a lot
over the course of the pandemic
and the argument was always right well
what's the relevant comparator for
sweden
is it the european average or is it you
know it's scandinavian peers
and just sort of how you how how you
decide that question is going to
determine what you think the lesson of
sweden is if you think the relevant
comparative for sweden is
it's scandinavian peers well then looks
like sweden was a disaster
relative to its peers if you think
sweden's competitor ought to be
uh your european union as a whole
sweden's kind of in the middle of the
path
despite having not really um you know
sweden would be
uh would be very low on this string of
the index i forget what i should looked
up there
but their actual volume was on the
oxford scale my guess says it's you know
uh it's down here somewhere near like
missouri or something like that
um but but okay but then here's what's
interesting right if you kind of
play this game of right thinking that
you know what the relevant peer
competitors are you can
show all kinds of interesting things so
if you pick uh north dakota and south
india well surely those are good
comparators
okay well they don't really have a very
different stringency index but to the
extent that they do
it looks like stringency led to more
deaths
maybe you think okay what about you know
the pacific northwest how about oregon
and washington
again you can you can find the opposite
of what you would think
is the prima facie thing to expect
um you can pick alabama mississippi
right
pretty clear those are peers right so i
just the point here is i
you see a lot of this i think people
play a lot of this game i think oh well
we can figure out what the we can figure
out what the relevant peers here are
um and in the process of that we can uh
make this but
again this is just kind of a cautionary
channel this is a kind of dangerous game
right um if you don't know uh if you
don't know how much people are sort of
loading the dice
when they choose these copywriters um
people are liable to be able to
demonstrate anything anything they want
uh
with with with comparisons like that
okay um so what are the one just uh what
are the sort of most sophisticated
methods that we've had available to us
um over the course of the pandemic for
identifying
um what are the sort of causal
determinants
of of different outcomes that we've seen
around the world
um i think they're sort of put them into
two categories right
we've had sort of sophisticated
statistical methods and then we've seen
some various attempts to use modeling
right these kind of
some things like the imperial college
model that were originally intended to
forecast
what the what the pandemic would do um
being used retrospectively to explain
why they uh why they did the things that
they did okay so
statistical methods right um uh here's
the game
right you want to know you want to know
did an intervention
have some outcome some causal outcome
right so you know imagine you
uh you want to know you know when kids
go to private school or they're better
at math
the kids who go to private school do
better on math tests okay
so what's the simplest thing you could
do you could look at kids who go to
private school and kids who don't go to
private school
and see whether the kids in private
school do better at math but obviously
right what would you find you'd probably
find oh yeah the kids of private school
do better
but right it would be because those kids
are wealthy
and wealthy kids on average right tend
to have a lot more
uh other right educational opportunities
and they tend to have
a lack of things that you know inhibit
their educational growth
like not having a healthy breakfast or
you know having
you know what at the obvious point right
that there are
lots of there are lots of things that
could cause wealth to lead to better
better math scores okay so um so
obviously
right you can't just look at whether
kids in private schools are doing that
get better than kids in public schools
well what you'd ideally like to do is
right take a whole bunch of kids and
randomly assign them to private school
and public school
uh but you can't do that okay you can't
do that i mean well you could do that
maybe but nobody's nobody's done
nobody's done this probably a lot of
people would
uh raise ethical flags if you tried to
do this so what you hope to do is you
sort of hope to wait for natural
experiments
so maybe right maybe you can wait until
i don't know cleveland one day
right decides it's gonna it needs to do
asbestos remediation in all
public schools and so it hands out
vouchers to all the kids to go to
private school
then you can maybe look and see right
you can look and see well did the kids
who got vouchers in cleveland
did their maths were suddenly go up okay
well that would probably be pretty
effective but you can imagine somebody
having to worry right
well i don't know maybe maybe it just so
happened that at the time that these
vouchers
were being given out right maybe it just
so happened that
um everyone was getting better at math
maybe maybe there was like that was the
exact time when the schoolhouse rock
episode came on tv
that was making everybody better at math
all at the same time right
so how do we know that it's the it's the
vouchers and the kids going to private
school that are doing it
well here's ideally what you'd love to
do right you'd love to be able to say
okay
let's look at the county i think it's
cuyahoga do i have that
i can never pronounce that cuyahoga
county which is where uh cleveland is in
right probably watching that um and
uh maybe hopefully you could look at
when
the vouchers get handed out right uh
to the private school kit to the public
kids in cleveland
right you could compare you not just
look at whether they're doing better at
math
but you could you could look at how much
better they're doing at math compared to
how the kids
are doing in the suburbs of cleveland so
the hope would be there right if it's
not the vouchers that are making the
kids do better at math
but it's some like underlying trend in
the data
right by comparing how much better
they're doing in cleveland
than they are doing in the suburbs you'd
be teasing out right
you'd be teasing out uh exactly what the
contribution
of the going to private school is um
and this is what's known as the
difference in difference method right
both both cleveland and suburbs have
some non-stationary data it's changing
over time
there's some difference but you're
looking for the difference in that
difference you're looking for
how much did the right the cleveland
math scores change
relative to what the overall trend was
in the county as a whole
but but right what crucially this
requires what this requires is
that overall you have what's known as
the part site what's what's
overall that you have what's known as
the parallel trends assumption okay
it requires that that whatever is going
on
in cleveland and its suburbs
is the same except for
except for the introduction of the uh
you know the vouchers to go to the
private school
okay um synthetic control methods are
not
really that interestingly different from
difference in difference methods
okay they suck when you first read the
bible this is like the sort of magic
bullet that enables us to do
uh right um what what might be harder
because
sometimes right it's hard to find right
it's hard to find
comparators there where parallel trends
are in place
so what what synthetic control method
does is
rather than comparing right the place
where the intervention happens
right to some particular operator
you use sort of something like machine
learning to build a synthetic
operator so here just this nice little
example right
um here's this place salta
that's interested introducing a new
tourism policy
it's trying to determine whether that
tourism policy is leading to increased
employment
in the tourism sector okay and all these
little
so here's the here's the uh here's when
that here's when the intervention
happens on the dotted line
right here's uh the black line is
salta's tourism
employment level and this these gray
lines right
these gray lines are just a whole set
of comp rate of comparable places uh
that didn't have a change in their
tourism policy
and what you do is you kind of you try
to find right
a way you try to find a subset of those
if you talk about a subset of these
places and a waiting for them
that produces this synthetic comparator
here and that's what this little dotted
line is
right and then the hope is that this
little dotted line
will be very close to what salta was
like prior to the intervention
and then if that's the case maybe you
can you can attribute
whatever difference happens sorry
whatever
uh difference happens afterward as
uh being attributable to the tourism
policy
but crucially right crucially the
parallel trends
uh still need to be in place okay
parallel trends still need to be in
place
it's still it's you you've you've you've
been able to make yourself a synthetic
control
that looks a lot like the your
your target area prior to the
intervention
but in a way the synthetic control
method um
enables you to hide differences that
that there that were there
that look like you try to get almost a
perfect match
right but that might be just because the
machine learning method is a really good
way
of data mining for a perfect match even
in spite of um in spite of an absence of
parallel trends
okay so um this isn't this nice paper
uh that was written right before the
pandemic started
uh by one of the uh one of the
developers of the synthetic control
method
i just want to read you a couple of uh
passages from it
right he says synthetic controls provide
many practical advantages for the
estimation effects of policy inventions
and other events of interest however
like any other statistical procedure
and especially for those in this
estimating causal effects
the copy of the results depends
crucially on the level of diligence
exerted in the application on the method
and on whether contextual and data
requirements are met in the empirical
application hand
okay in this article emphasize the
notion that mechanical applications of
synthetic controls
that do not take into account the
context the investigation or the nature
of the data
are risky enterprises an avid in
particular identifies two
uh two um sort of
crucial designer audit that needs to be
in place for the synthetic control
method to work this is right
on the one hand it's advisable uh
to select for the donor pool right
that's the bunch of places you're gonna
machine learn
uh just a synthetic control out of uh
affected by the same
regional economic shocks he's an
economist as the unit where the
intervention happens
on the other hand if spillover effects
are substantial
and affect units in close geographical
proximity those units may provide a
biased estimate of the counterfactual
outcome
without intervention for the unit
affected by uh the intervention right so
think of it this way right you want to
know let's say
um yeah right this was the mask study
in germany the eastern trolls looked at
gena as a place where
this last mandate was introduced you
want to know whether the masked mandate
led people to uh like like cases to go
down
okay but you're worried about the
following thing right it's plausible
that when yin
introduces masked mandates places around
in the proximity of vienna
people will start wearing masks because
they see you know their
their close relatives live in yena they
have friends in yena uh they commute to
yana and there some of them come back
and so you get the spillover effect of
mass wearing
right in the regions surrounding you
at the same time right you want to make
sure that you
are right um sampling from some place
regionally close because we know right
we know in retrospect
if you think back to that sort of
stockholm hamburg
chart that i showed you we know that um
that there's that parallel trends wildly
breaks down
as you as you get geographically far
away right
if you compare sweden uh if you compare
stockholm and hombor
uh you're going to see even though even
though maybe stockholm
was much closer to let's say florida in
terms of what the
public health interventions going on
there were you're going to see a lot
more similarity between
stockholm and hamburg the are between
stockholm and florida
for for whatever reasons and i'm
pretending to know what they are for
whatever reasons climate
uh network spread whatever it is
whatever causes
uh geographic distance to result in
different outcomes
you're going to see different things
there so you kind of have these two
desiderata
and they really i think in epidemics
anyway
they really fundamentally conflict right
because i want at the one time i want to
make sure
um that right i want to make sure
uh that my that the members of my donor
pool are not being affected by spillover
effects
i want to make sure that my donor pool
that i'm comparing nana to
does not include any places where the
residents would be seeing the res the
people in union putting masks on
and wearing masks themselves but i also
want to make sure that
whatever region i'm looking at is
geographically close enough
that right the kind of thing that we
expect from nonlinear phenomena where
there's just clumpiness in the data
causing waves to appear regionally in
all kinds of ways that we can't
right hope to understand certainly not
you know in media array as they're
happening
um so we need to be we need to be
careful about that
and then right um and then uh
right timing is also crucial in this so
if you go look for example the end of
paper
uh when they they they sort of point out
you know they ran the study
at first and they didn't find they
didn't find the effect they were looking
for and then they said oh well
actually it's because we didn't realize
at first that
um when you have a mask mandate uh and
the government announces that the mass
made mandate is going to come into place
people will start wearing the masks
before the mandate occurs
so immediately now you've got you've
introduced a degree of flexibility right
and
in in right it's not it's not it's no
longer obvious
exactly when this dotted line is
happening um right and if you have
if you allow yourself um some
flexibility
in in deciding um when the dotted line
when the dotted line happens uh then you
really
got yourself into a situation where you
have a tremendous
what i would call a do ham problem right
you ham was the guy that taught us
that um when you're trying to test the
scientific hypothesis
it's a bad thing if there are too many
flexible
uh alter you know auxiliary hypotheses
that you need
to connect the data to your hypothesis
so if you have too much flexibility
in deciding what the actual impactful
date
of a mass mandate is that's going to
really sort of hurt
the inferential power of your study okay
i want to kind of wrap up here pretty
quickly so i'm going to uh
um i'm going to skip a couple things
here and just kind of
get to my conclusion here um
here's my i think my main conclusion
right so non-linear phenomena
often create the illusions of patterns
that require explanation
i think we saw this both in the case of
the warming hiatus and climate science
and we saw this happen sort of week
after week month after month
over the course of the pandemic people
uh sort of trying to
um make cause causal inference you know
in meteorary as as things are going on
right as the phenomena themselves are
unfolding
um uh and i think that's especially sort
of epistemically risky right when you
have
these non-linear films like creating
these patterns that have the illusion of
requiring explanation
and you're trying to do the causal
inference on the fly
right when you don't really know what
you don't you don't
have the requisite if you think about
that you know
the thing that abit is telling us about
uh the
synthetic control method right he's
basically warning you if you don't have
a good handle
on what's causing background noise and
causing the zigging and zagging
you cannot use this method um and you
know it was i think pretty obvious
in retrospect at least that we just
didn't have that kind of grip on
um what was making the various uh
features of the data about uh
about those differences um be present so
we just didn't really have the
opportunity to have the kind of grip on
the data
that abbott is warning us there that we
have to have to use these kind of causal
enforcement methods
um and uh i think you know this this is
especially episodically risky
uh when the decisions that are being
supported by those inferences are
uh particularly high stakes and i think
that that'll need to
i don't need to argue for the claim that
uh we made a lot of decisions
over the course of the pandemic that
were that were very high stakes okay
great thank you all i think i'll stop
there
thanks so much uh eric for that
wonderful presentation
dissecting many of the plots and graphs
that we've all been witnessing over the
past few months
and uh puzzled over how these sort of
policy decisions
were supposedly guided entirely by the
data but it's quite clear
that you know the underlying complex
non-linearities make it not so simple
to go from the data to
policy decisions and i think the point
that you were making about
the masking was particularly
interesting because of how the
initially i had gathered
that the masking
not emphasizing masking had to do with
the fact that there was a shortage
of n95 mass because the public was
buying them up
when medical staff needed healthcare
workers
frontline healthcare workers were there
were shortages for them
so it's very interesting how all these
kinds of external factors
play in along with what the data is
telling us thank you so much for that
exposition and i'd like to open up
the floor now and we've have um several
questions
ty did you want to um uh read the first
one
yep sorry just a meeting here first one
yep so do you think we make peace with
the linear system
for using it to pin down conditionally
sufficient
causal factors and history
and other social sciences to pin down
necessary
factors and do we use non-linear
for the prediction purpose
i'm gonna have to see if i can look at
that myself
is that uh it was up higher
back at the beginning with the linear
system
using it
i'll tell you what i'll copy it and yeah
i think i see it here
um can you flush that out for me a
little bit
uh it's sanjeev uh i'm not sure i get
quite get the question
uh you can make peace with layer systems
oh i'm eric i'm an economist training
and we use linear system all the time to
pin down causal factors
but what you are saying is totally valid
given that we live in a very very
complex world so it
seems like non-linear system is more
more appropriate but in order to make
sense
you know how to pass out the reality
that's complex reality and that's when
linear system helps us you know through
cetera
look i mean i i don't doubt that i don't
doubt that um
you know 10 years from now we'll be able
to sort through all this data
and we'll be able to learn some things
um
but i think it's gonna i think it's it's
gonna require
you can't i take sort of the main point
of the ability paper
to be you can't do this kind of causal
inference
until you have a pretty good handle on
what the background noise looks like
right um and so trying to do this stuff
kind of
on the fly you know in in june
july august september of 2020 right
um when you know i mean right
um i think i was pointing out like i
came back from california
to florida in june at that point neither
california nor florida had really had
very much infection at all um why
i mean we don't we don't really know it
could have been you know some people
think it's
because of uh the climate um
you know once once maybe we've been able
we've seen the whole thing unfold
we'll be able to tease all this out and
we'll be able to do the kind of
inference where you
you know are able to hold everything
fixed or at least convince yourself that
you're using a sample where everything
is relatively fixed but but doing this
you know doing this in march april may
june july of 2020
um i mean obviously we were going to do
it right i mean it's i'm not
it was it was sort of baked into the
cake that we were going to do this
um but uh
it also should have been i think
made a little bit more clear i think
that this this was hard because you know
what we didn't know enough about what
real what the relative appears to
compare to was
we didn't know enough about what was it
just was there was just a mess of data
coming in and we were making inferences
too fast
i mean um no and i eric i take your
point that
you know the the timing of your
returning to florida and the rise in
hospitalization
right i mean i think you know one of the
intriguing things about the pandemic has
been
how you know as you were pointing out we
were trying to find
reasons before the phenomenon actualized
fully so for example you know
prematurely people were coming with with
explanations
and writing articles about you know how
come indians for example
why were the few cases in india and you
know maybe it's
vitamin d because it's a war hot country
maybe this may be that i mean there's so
so many
trees were felt for you know
hypothesizing about these
and less than you know two months later
you know
the pandemic came roaring back in india
with the variant rendering all of those
speculations
completely moot right i mean there's
there's something known as the sports
illustrated curse i know people know
what this is and
the idea is that if you get your p if
you get your picture on the cover of
sports illustrated
you're going to go into a slump
afterwards you know
the obvious explanation of that is that
sports is you know mean reverting
right right you're going to end up on
the cover when you're at the end of a
hot streak and you're going to mean
revert
the worst thing that could happen to you
in the pandemic was to be on the cover
of scientific american is like
look how well india is doing look how
well new mexico is doing
that was the that was like that was the
sports illustrated curse it was
guaranteed if somebody wrote you up
as a case study and how to manage the
pandemic that within
you know two months tops you were going
to be uh
the poster child of what not to do right
happens you know we watch this happen a
week after week and month after month
yeah
so um there's a very interesting
question from
uh carl hofer who asked you know in
terms
of policy uh recommendations how to
avoid causal attribution errors
and what i mean what is the what flows
from your analysis
yeah i i mean i just thought this right
from the get-go
uh in the pandemic and i feel quite
vindicated in my in my belief in this
early on that we
should have been uh we should have been
listening to the risk to the sort of
conventional wisdom
about about epidemics and how to manage
them
uh and this business of you know trying
to figure out on the fly
what was working and what wasn't working
uh
was not a good idea so i mean i i think
again you know i'm i'm not i'm not uh
i'm not very smart and i'm not a
statistician and i'm not the one that's
going to be able to do this but i
i'm reasonably confident that there are
smart people out there
who you know as i say down the road will
be able to tease apart what happened
uh you know but it's going to take years
um
and it just seemed to me it was it
seemed to be foolish to be
uh you know every month um revising what
guidelines were in response to
inferences that were being made
uh on the fly like that particularly
when particularly when even
you know even the normal even the normal
procedures of peer review which we all
know
are you know we all know that ordinary
peer review is not what
uh is not what secures the reliability
of science
much more in-depth criticism has to take
place than just
two referees before we before we get
good science
but not even that was was in place you
know in much of the pandemic it was
stopped being uploaded to pre-print
archives and uh then
making the new york times two days later
and
yeah i mean i i think there was this
sort of uh
this was a perfect storm of you know
journalistic
exuberance coupled with you know as you
said
preprints would come out hypothesizing
stuff and you know not uh not peer
reviewed
in detail not corroborated with other
independent analyses for cross-checking
etc and yeah but
and politics i mean everybody had
everybody had convictions about the
nature of the pandemic that were
that were linked to to politics i mean
that's why i kind of started with the
trump voting counties i mean we you know
the you know the motorcycle rally they
were some
just sort of transparently i mean
maybe those weren't really like you know
being done by rigorous scientists or
anything like that but
but but we're pretty clearly people were
people were eager to hear
that you know um their their
whatever their political convictions
were those were virtuous and led to
good health outcomes right which i think
in retrospect you know now it kind of
looks like that
seems unlikely um there um
so there's a was a really nice question
from from chris mink
hi chris uh that you're here um
and his question is what is the scope of
your criticism of causal attribution
you've given various cautionary tales
but is your claim even stronger
that we have not or maybe even cannot
make any justified causal claims
regarding differential performance due
to the npis in the pandemic
take the sturgis rally as a concrete
example which was in august 2020 and
brought
between 450 000 to 500 000 people
from over half of all u.s counties to a
week-long event with no mitigation
measures in place
do you think it's impossible to make any
calls and claims regarding the role of
this event
yeah absolutely absolutely impossible
and and
this and the studies that that claim to
do this were
were ripped apart by smarter people than
me i mean um
yeah that's not no way
uh so again i you know i think as i said
i think like
eventually uh various methods will be
able to tease apart some of these things
but um but i mean but eric i mean there
is
a role to play for super spreader events
i mean super spreading events
are are um
are real right i mean they might be they
might be but i mean
um they might be but uh um
uh okay
i mean sure uh but but
being able to look i it's i'm not
i'm not denying that um i'm not denying
it when people get together
uh for a motorcycle rally they're
probably going to spread some disease
but the idea that you could tease out uh
as
as was done in some of these studies
tease out the actual you know number of
cases
uh you know to attributable i see yeah
trivia
and then measure the economic damage of
it and and whatever
when you know again i think in
retrospect
i think it's reasonably clear that um
it just so happened that the sturgis
motorcycle rally happened
in a part of the country that was
that was you know due for their wave i
mean it's not
it seems it seems unlike i'll put it
this way right
if you think if you think that if you
think that the sturgis motorcycle rally
caused all the cases that were that were
attributed to it
then in some sense yup so facto think
that we're not for the sturgis
motorcycle rally the kind of you know
plain states uh would have somehow
been magically spared from covet i mean
that's what we that's the fact that
we're being asked to believe
right if you actually if you if you
actually think that that's
that that's that's what the motorcycle
rally did then in some sense you think
but for it right
uh but but in the end we sort of know
that like every state has
other than other than like a few really
small outliers
like maine and vermont and hawaii right
and alaska
and you know every state eventually kind
of got its due
in some sense uh so it seems implausible
to me that like people were able to
uh and and and then if you if you
actually look at
if you actually look at uh at what they
did to try to show that i mean
i could i'll send you stuff yeah no but
i mean i was curious about you know
there were also these cases
of uh churches where people
were i mean people were singing and it
was shown
that you know exercising your vocal
cords in that fashion
kind of spread the aerosols you know um
what do you make of those kinds of super
special events right
they were many too i mean
we're gonna i honestly think we're gonna
have to wait and see on
this i think a lot of those i do think a
lot of that stuff was
um kind of kind of cobbled together
pretty hastily
priya would you like me to take the next
question please go ahead yeah
we're going down the line uh from a
participant i would like to know if it
would be
possible to understand covet as a black
swan
is it possible to cross data from
natural and social sciences
is it not a risk in construct uh i think
constructing artificial
parallel trends
uh let me see if i can read that one
this is that from
a little further back i know sometimes
it's not easy to scroll through
chat feature here i'll just post it
again
well certainly i mean certainly it's a
it's a it's a black swan in the sense
that i i
understand the black swan is just
something that nobody would have
expected to have happened
um uh so certainly it's a
so certainly it's a black swan in that
sense um
is it possible to cross data from
natural social science yeah look i'm
again i think i think um i i
i'm reasonably hopeful that in the long
run as i said we'll be able to sort
through
some of this and we'll be able to
disentangle what some of the natural
causes
were from whether just being you know
natural non-linear
variability uh et cetera uh
but uh not yet i don't think so
okay next question begins with the
favorable comment thanks for the
fascinating talk
what evidential role do first order
causal slash mechanistic explanations
play in non-linear phenomena for
instance
let's say that prior to doing a
large-scale tourist program
there was a small focus group that
showed that the intervention
is effective on a micro scale does this
have
any evidential value that the tourist
intervention
will have some efficacy when put out on
a large scale
i mean that goes case by case right i
can't answer that generally right
but i think often um often in the case
of like epidemics what's what's usually
going on with something like that is
something that's being you know tested
uh
in a kind of you know um microclinical
setting and then being extrapolated to a
social setting so
you know you might do something like put
masks on mannequins
you know in a room and have them spray
aerosols out and see
whether you know what portion of that of
the air cells is trapping
um but that doesn't tell you you know it
doesn't tell you whether you're
preventing on the uh
and then you know a minimum infectious
dose from getting to the other person
it doesn't tell you uh you know it just
certainly doesn't tell you anything
about what
mask mandates do in terms of mask
wearing right
um you could be 100 convinced that mask
wearing
reduces spread without believing that
masked mandates do
particularly maybe if you thought that
you know mask wearing for
so i you know i think i think uh this is
right the sort of
standard view in clinical settings uh
about n95 masks was you shouldn't go
into a room
with one of them hoping that it will
protect you for more than 20 minutes
that was i think the usual guideline
like go in there where you're in 95 mask
but get out within 20 minutes why not
because n95 masks
only last 20 minutes or something like
that but because people are not very
good at not sticking their fingers in
there
after about 20 minutes um what about you
know what about people who were working
eight hour shifts with a mask like
so um uh so yeah i mean
uh obviously um you can get causal
information
uh from these abstract settings like
menu putting
masculine mannequins and seeing what
kind of aerosols come through them or
whatever
but getting from there to knowing what
um the actual impact of let's say you
know a masked
mandate on an entire municipality or
county or state or whatever is going to
be
um not just for one day but for months
right again remembering that like if
this was
this was a marathon not a sprint right
uh something that maybe protected people
while they were complying perfectly for
a few days might not have had value
if over the course of months those
[ __ ] stopped being forced or whatever
so
um i guess i think you know there's a uh
there's a little bit of you can be you
can glean from from things like that but
i mean there's a reason why we there's a
reason why
um for example economists uh
like to look at the difference in
difference method rather than
just focus groups or something like that
because it's difficult to extrapolate
from those contexts to broader contexts
so but but eric do you what do you make
of the six feet
in the social distancing do you think
that was also
i thought i was i i thought that was
well understood to have been made up and
not
particularly i i so my this i you know
my understanding
the late the latest book is that you
know
it's more about um it's more about a
number of people in the room
how much time they spend in the room the
quality of ventilation in the room
uh and not so much about uh it's not
like in other words
i i thought the consensus now was not so
much that i
i don't just directly transmit the virus
to you
i kind of fill the room up with it
that's right and uh so the six feet i
think most people started thinking about
that much
right okay um
i'll freak out the last question i think
we have on the list here
uh what about things like surfaces
versus airborne transmission building on
what you were just saying
that the ladder is more important
airborne transmission
strikes me as something most of us
myself included
feel like we've learned over the course
of the pandemic
and which has informed reasonable
changes of course
when it comes to mitigation strategies
so focusing less on cleaning for
instance more on ventilation indoors and
outdoor
a concrete version of the question just
asked did we have no reason
for making those changes oh look so i
mean those are those
those are quite different right i mean
so i think it's a surface thing like we
know
like that's pretty clear like formites
don't transmit
coronavirus it's just like the washing
of your groceries you know all that was
for nothing right but that's but i mean
that's a that's a that's a
that's like you can ruling out a
potential causal mechanism
right is a lot easier i mean it's not
it's not easy it still was it still took
us a few months i take it or whatever
but that right and and and and
and and separating um and separating
right whether again six feet versus
filling up a room thing
i mean those are things that you can
those are things that you can determine
in a microscopic context right those are
things
those are sort of basic mechanical facts
that you can i think determine in a
microscopic context
but that's quite different from you know
you can mix
you can make guesses from facts like
that to what
interventions are going to do socially
but social interventions are
unbelievably complicated
right i mean this was again this was
something that was like this was
something that i think you know was
widely known and understood among public
health experts
prior to the covet 19 pandemic that
closing schools for
more than six weeks is ineffective
why not because not because of annie not
because of anything you could learn
by watching what happens with kids in
school and the way the virus is
no because the kids are kids
and they crave social interaction and if
you close the schools they eventually
start congregating
in other ways so it you know
i like to remind people that the demon
epidemiology
is from the greek word for people uh and
you know it's uh the things that we're
talking about here are not
just you know microscopic facts about
how the virus is transmitted we're
talking about like
what happens when you institute
public health measures and you then have
to wait and see
like what people are going to do right
that's very different than being able to
predict what will happen if people
actually do exactly what you say
right right right which never happens
people don't do exactly what you say
never that just you know that's not how
that's not how policy making works you
don't when you're evaluating a a policy
intervention
you don't just imagine that everyone's
going to do exactly what you tell them
to do
because it doesn't go that way right
um so i guess there's one kind of yeah
one final question has come in and
and the question is that it's been usual
to miss cultural issues when news
news presents data on how to think about
cultural traditions that make for
difficult comparisons
how does one take that into account do
we need
observations from other fields like
yeah this was ethnography thing i think
that set me off uh early on the pandemic
about this kind of stuff so we started
seeing i was in california early
and we started seeing early on in
california that like um
latino communities were having uh
more infection than non-latino
communities
i started seeing people talk about oh
it's because
you know fill in the blank about how
latino people behave
and i just thought no
my guess my wild guess is it's because
these people have
jobs that don't allow them to work over
zoom
right exactly you know let's not leap to
like stereotypes about
how various ethnic groups like comport
themselves
uh and so that was like you know uh
one thing that i think set me off kind
of early about like let's not
be super hasty in making these causal
attributions
but on the other hand i mean it is
undeniable that communities of color
were hit much much harder both
economically
epidemiologically and and in terms of we
already knew
that the care medical care
um for these communities is not as
robust as it is
absolutely look i mean so i mean uh this
was i remember seeing this
uh i think maybe adam hiller who
asked a question and they pointed this
out to me somebody did early on
that the the uh
the number of beds per capita hospital
events for tablet and manhattan was like
three or four times higher than in
queens
and lo and behold like they were bad you
know that where where were the hospitals
in new york overwhelmed
wow in queens uh and of course also
right i mean you know
the policy look i mean the policy
these policy interventions were being
made by
uh you know wealthy
white people um and so they were you
know a lot of them were
designed to protect us uh
we were the ones deciding what were
essential services and what weren't
essential services etcetera etcetera
so you know and then you know of course
also
uh in the us particularly among you know
particularly african-americans obviously
we
we unfortunately have kind of
pre-existing
um you know uh
bad bad health that's you know obviously
the result of
nice other racial inequalities etc so
there's a
whole complex mixture in there but but
but i
but i but i really doubt i mean i'd have
i shouldn't say i shouldn't say it i
doubt i should just say you'd be
on my back burner right to think that
what's going on there
is something like oh it's because
you know it's because latino people
behave this way or it's because black
people behave that way or whatever
like let's leave that for last right
yeah
and curiously that seems to be where
people go first yeah of course
of course absolutely absolutely yeah
so um if there are no further
questions ty do you see any i think we i
think we got them all
i think so um
thank you so much eric for this
wonderful walk and um
we really look forward to uh the
discussion tomorrow
it's gonna be great i've talked about me
a bit about what
it's gonna be it's gonna shift years to
a much more sort of
broad spectrum look at things so people
i think people don't want to miss it i
think stephanie's stuff's going to be
super interesting tomorrow so thank you
everyone for attending and stephanie
we're really looking forward to
um the discussion tomorrow thanks
everyone and see you at 30 pm tomorrow
yeah